hey everyone this is jeremy schieffling
with khan academy i'm so excited that
you join us today
not just because khan academy really
wants to support you during this
challenging time but as a former
kindergarten teacher this session that's
dedicated to elementary school education
and elementary school students is one
that's near and dear to my heart and
that's why i'm so excited to introduce
you to lisa orcutt who's one of our
amazing khan academy ambassadors
like me lisa is based in california and
is currently in the same boat as
everyone else trying to serve her fourth
graders remotely um with the tools that
are at her disposal so that being said
we'll get into khan academy in a second
lisa but if you wouldn't mind opening up
a little bit about your background as an
educator i think that would help folks
understand where you're coming from
so i started off as a sub when i was
working through my master's program
and at the time i didn't want to be a
teacher it was just an easy way for me
to do
all the curriculum that's required for a
master's degree
while
um having the ability to be flexible in
your schedule um anybody who's taken a
master's program even if it's online
like mine was it's a lot of work
and
what ended up happening is it backfired
i fell in love with teaching and decided
that that's what i wanted to do
and so i i finished up my master's
program and then entered my
credentialing program and if everything
goes right even with the shutdowns i
will be induction next year but i've
been teaching full-time in the classroom
since 2017.
so i'm on my
third school year
um
teaching pretty much as the teacher on
record and
that's where my journey has taken me so
far but it's five to six years counting
my sub years
very cool i'm guessing when you were
back in your teacher education days it
never prepared you for teaching remotely
during a pandemic so
here we are no
well that being said if we just rewind
the table they prepared us for that's
right
um if we just go back a little bit to
like you're sort of beginning with khan
academy
tell us a little bit about why you chose
khan academy and why it was sort of
useful for you and your students
so
i was long-term subbing at a russian
charter school and i had a student
and for people who wonder why there's a
russian charter school
the slavic community in northern
california is very large
and a lot of them want a lot of people
in this law the community want to keep
their culture and their language
because we know through social science
that that's something that gets lost
very quickly
and they didn't want to lose that and so
they set up a public charter school
where they can they take any students
and
um but one of the things that is
mandatory is they have
russian class which teaches the language
and the culture and the food
and i got hired on to long term sub for
them in a fourth grade class of all
things
um and i had a student who was testing
sixth seventh eighth grade in math
well at fourth grade when most of your
students are classified as english
language learners you're pretty slow
going on math because this is where the
word problems get really intense
but she was breezing through the work
and we all know that when kids get bored
they act out they get distracted they
start doing things they shouldn't
so i went and got one of the middle
school books
and was having her work on those
she was breezing through that she wasn't
you know she was bored everything was
coming out
and
i started looking at things that my
husband had recommended and those were
more geared towards college students so
it didn't work for her either and
finally i reached out to a colleague and
i was going what do i do for this young
lady she is too fast for the rest of the
class and if i go at her speed the rest
of the class is going to fall behind and
she recommended khan academy
because she used it to study for her
c-set
and for those of you not in california
the c-set is what we use to test for our
initial credentialing process in
california
and so i pulled it up and i was like oh
this is amazing
and i set her up on grade four so on our
grade level and at the very bottom
of the
grade level
page it has something called course
challenge
and what that is it tests you on all the
major standards of that grade i said
start here take this if you get less
than an 80
that's where we're going to figure out
where you need to to do your work
and
um
she hit
seventh eighth grade word problems and
that's where she kind of hit the brick
wall
but she spent the rest of the time
listening to our math lessons and doing
the khan academy to work on those
seventh eighth grade word problems
and i was able to slow down and go the
pace of my fourth graders
and she loved it her mom loved it her
mom especially loved it because when she
went back to her dad's
um because her dad lived out of out of
country um during the summer she would
have some way to stay up on her
schooling
and i fell in love with it after that
and when i got hired on as a teacher
where i work now i started doing it to
help backlog and support my students
because i teach in a very
low income
um low
academic
scoring demographic
so i use it to kind of help catch up my
students who are struggling as well as
my students who are advanced so that i
can focus our solo math time where i am
teaching in the classroom
on grade level stuff but they still have
that extra support and scaffolding that
they may need
i love that story because it really
brings out sort of the essence of why
sal khan built this in the first place
not just to have a bunch of worksheets
online but to actually differentiate and
serve students at scale whether they're
far ahead or far behind
i have a couple more questions before
for you lisa before we go to the
audience questions um i want to cut to
the chase here and address the 800 pound
gorilla in the room
which is
you know if someone was starting with
khan academy today
and there are literally thousands of
elementary educators trying to do
exactly that this week
what would you recommend for them to get
set up quickly how can they bring khan
academy to their students in an
effective way even in this remote
learning environment
no first of all don't panic um there is
a learning curve for khan academy even
for teachers
thankfully though
sal and his team of developers
bless them i mean bless them because
they have made it so smooth you can
import your google your your google
classroom if you already have one set up
um the only thing you have to do
manually
is like our district the google class
the the google names in google classroom
are actually the students
um student id numbers
so you as the teacher have to go in and
manually change to their first and last
name but you can actually import
everybody which means you don't have to
send out invites you don't have to wait
for them to log in and um
you don't even technically have to
assign
anything
you can just tell them where to start
and so that's what i usually do at the
beginning of the year is i import my
students before the first day
and then i don't assign anything yet
because what i do is the first couple
weeks we're getting in standards what i
expect of you what are expectations what
are behaviors and i introduce them to
khan academy
and i tell them to play with the website
have some fun get used to it figure it
out if you have questions i'll help you
because i'm teaching
what we call intermediate
uh elementary level so my students are a
little bit more independent so they can
play around with it and figure it out
and then i can be a little hands-off
um after that i explain what we're going
to be using it for
and one of the things that i instruct
them on is i tell them this is how
you're going to be using it
and i show them how to find that
challenge test
and then i get out the toys
and as an ambassador i have several
pencils that were gifted to me and i
have some other prizes like i have some
pencils that my students have gotten
over the years they don't want to keep
from parties and things like that
i put some of my crocheted goodies in
there because i make my own stuff i buy
a lot of stuff off of wish and geek
so like i have
let me pull it out where is it so i have
stuff like this and i get them in bulk
and i tell my students
that for every grade level you complete
you get a prize
if you complete the one for our grade
level you get one of the khan academy
pencils
and another prize from the prize bin
so now there's this incentive for them
to want to do it but the rule is
you have to have an 80 or higher on the
grade level challenge test
and you have to complete all of the
lessons for fourth grade
and i kind of let the kids go it that
way because when they hit that 80
percent that means they're proficient
i'm not expecting perfection these are
children
it's not going to work kids are going to
get bored they're going to mentally
check out
when they hit less than 80 i tell them
that's where your struggle is and it'll
tell you what section of that grade
level you are struggling with
those are the mastery lessons that you
need to take
that'll help you get caught up on our
grade level
and i don't use it as my sole means of
teaching
i use this as a scaffold this is
strictly for support
because by law in california keep this
in mind by law in california students
have to be exposed to all grade level
materials
so this is my scaffold now if i have a
student when we do our initial tests
because in california we do those kind
of benchmark testing where we find out
where they are at the beginning of the
year the middle of the year and the end
of the year
if i assembly test being higher i have
them start at fourth grade and work
their way up
and this is my way of giving them those
challenges because again higher
performing students get bored easily
they start getting in trouble and then
we have all maths
don't
freak out if your kids are going very
slow
because for some students this is going
to be new it's going to be a struggle
and if you have an el student like i
have a
10 percent of my classes english
language learner
they're going to struggle with it more
because this is all written in formal
academic language and that is the
hardest thing for el students to learn
that's great so just to recap a couple
of the key things there i think first of
all
you're definitely not in a rush to sort
of roll out khan academy no matter what
you're hearing from your district
because it does take time even when lisa
has her students right in front of her
it takes them a few weeks to sort of get
them acclimated to this so one thing you
could say is hey i've rostered you on
google classroom or i've rostered you
manually in the student section
now all you're going to do for the first
week just come in here and search for
the things you're interested in whether
you want to search for multiplying
fractions or addition or what have you
just play around with it
and that actually sort of leads into
another question which is coming to us
from courtney now i'm going to switch
some questions from the audience here
courtney says these exercises are really
cool but i also see that khan academy
has all these videos
um would you recommend using the videos
as well or just focusing on the
exercises how would you prioritize sure
use the videos um so
story time um our district had some
issues with curriculum for the last few
years and i was using khan academy a lot
to show the demonstration videos
because sal and anyone else who's doing
the videos with him
really breaks it down into nice easy to
digest chunks and for some students they
are visual learners
just doing the problems for a visual
learner isn't going to make any sense
they need to see someone
doing the work so they can follow along
and for some students they need to hear
that audio instruction for other
students they just want to read because
sal is really cool and he puts
everything in closed captions on the
bottom
and so it's very adaptive
so it has all
four modalities of learning built into
the videos
i encourage the kids to watch them
especially when they hit that brick wall
of struggle and it's like you're
struggling with word problems here's
here's the video on how sal shows you
how to break out all the important
information
and
sal walks through it step by step
and the kids can walk through it with
them and then they can try it again on
their own
don't skip the videos the videos are
very very vital
and they are amazing to help your
students particularly if you use this
for small groups
or
math centers which is what i've been
using it for before we went on
hiatus
is i would pull a small group after the
main lesson we would work on what they
needed to work on and i would have some
students on our curriculum digital site
because again our curriculum's slightly
hybridized
and then i would have others doing
um
prodigy all that good stuff and then i
would have another group doing khan
academy and they would cycle through all
three or four or five depending on how
many you want to use so they're getting
the same stuff from multiple sources to
kind of build on those skills
and the videos are something that i love
about khan academy because i do have
those students they have to see it
being done and they can slow it down
they can pause it they can look at what
he's trying to pick out and try to
figure it out on their own and then they
can get that courage to ask for help
very cool
and so now sylvia your fellow california
educator has a sort of advanced level
question for you which is okay if we
played this all out you know we've
started with khan academy our kids have
started watching some videos doing some
basic exercises maybe they've taken
those course mastery challenges at the
end of each course just to see where
they are
but now we're going to fast forward a
little bit maybe like six months from
now and our kids are hopefully coming
back to school in september
and they're way behind because it's been
tough to sort of fill in those gaps over
the next couple months
what can i use khan academy for to help
my students be ready for that next grade
level even with all the challenges in
our way
use it to fill in the gaps have the kids
do it as their homework one of the
things that i've taken as a philosophy
for homework is if your child if you're
if your student is on grade level it's
fine to send them grade level homework
if your student is performing below
grade level i try to send them home
remedial homework to develop those
skills
so i've had students where
they're still struggling with number
sense i'm not going to send them
fractions when we're working on
fractions in class home is homework
because i don't know if their family or
anyone in their family knows how to help
them i don't know
if they even have anyone who can help
them
so i'm going to send them stuff on
number sense to build that up and if i
know that student has access to a
computer at home i'm going to be going
all right i want you to work on number
sense on khan academy and if you can't
find it send me a message on dojo you
have my email address you can email me
and i will assign it to you because you
can do assignments and then you don't
have to worry about trying to find it
and then my students can build that also
that sense of independence studying
because we are coming up with
something that i've discovered and i
think a lot of teachers have discovered
is over the last few years a lot of
students have slipped into this
passive learning mentality of just tell
me what you want me to tell you
and i want them to build that sense of
independence and that sense of
taking ownership of their education
um
so that's one way that i do it is i'm
like okay if you can't do this without
me holding your hand and just giving you
fill in the blanks i'm going to give you
what i know you can do and i'm just
going to increase the hardness a little
bit
because we're building that strength and
so if i can only lift a five pound
weight why am i going
to go home and try to lift a 25 pound
weight
totally so i'm going to go home and i'm
going to work with a six pound weight
and then when that gets too light i'm
going to go up to an 8 pound weight and
then i'm going to work up to that 25
pound weight because if a kid is working
and they can only lift five pounds and
you send them home telling them to bench
press 25 pounds they're not going to do
it they're going to give up
it's always having that sort of zone of
proximal development that's sort of
right next challenge not too much not
too little um actually this idea of
empowering kids sort of feeds directly
into a question from sandy and this is
such a great question from sandy because
it speaks to the dilemma for elementary
educators in particular during this time
you know it's tough enough to motivate
and keep students engaged in an
elementary classroom but now that we're
in this remote learning environment
how do you actually hold students
accountable given all the other
distractions and the difficulty you have
reaching out and engaging them
you can't not in the sense that we could
in the classroom
um you got to remember their parents are
stressed some of their parents have lost
their jobs
some of these kids maybe the older
sibling looking after the little
siblings
and so what you can do is just encourage
them to take that independence look i
know you're stressed you're scared
you're afraid you don't know what's
going on your parents are freaking out
your parents are at work and you're by
yourself and you know
just use this as a focal point give me
10 minutes a day and that's all i ask
that way we don't fall behind
and
because i'm going to tell you right now
if you start calling parents bobby
didn't do his math work this week most
of the parents can be like i really
don't care i'm more worried about
feeding bobby at this point
you know
so it's about understanding and being
patient that for some of these kids
they're not going to do it
but for some of these kids they are
going to do it and they are going to
thrive
and so it's understanding that
it's our zone of control now we they are
no longer directly in our proximity we
can do our best and call it
a day on that we can
adore them from afar and encourage them
and remind them that we want them to
succeed and just hope they'll take it
upon themselves to finally listen
and i actually want to pick up on that
threat of parents and families because
as someone with too young elementary
school kid myself at home i know that
i'm struggling personally to keep them
engaged and to stay in touch with their
teachers
um any wants to know lisa do you have
any tips for making con easy for parents
obviously to your point they're stressed
they've got a lot on their shoulders
how can we explain this whole con thing
to the parent community
make it very well known that this is
free
because the second you say it's free
guaranteed free most parents will relax
just a little bit
um and explain to them
you know it's really easy to play around
with just go have fun the kids can
figure it out it's very independent and
easy to use
if you need help please email me there's
lots of help pages there's videos on how
to use it and it's just a matter of take
your time click around
play with it
and if you still have questions i can
help you
um and for those of you wondering how
you talk to parents if you don't want to
do email or you need to talk to them
over the phone star 67 or set up google
voice
it'll mask your phone number
no must no fuss
um
and
explain to them that you can assign work
if they're worried about the kids not
finding the stuff that's good for them
because you as the teacher can actually
see specifically where they're
growing and how they're doing and
what they're working on
so it's not
fully independent because you can still
monitor and check on things
cool and then sort of continuing this
theme of making sure that folks feel
supported on the home front um i think
you could probably speak to this lisa
given the underserved community that you
teach in but kristin says the struggle
for me is that many of my students don't
have the technology or their internet
access to do online learning
any recommendations for filling that
sort of digital gap
most digital learning programs um such
as khan academy have apps
i think it's called con con kids or
something like that
yeah i'll just clarify there so khan
academy has an app that very much
replicates the exact thing you see
um on the website
for ios you know iphones ipads android
android phones and android tablets and
those are all free and you can download
those from the app stores in addition
there's a separate app called con kids
that's really dedicated to sort of um
two-year-old six-year-old set
yeah and if you have an el student the
con kids is a really good way to help
them develop their english skills
because it teaches that phonetical
awareness that is very hard to teach in
distance learning
um
and for the the lack of technology a lot
of districts are stepping up and letting
students check out
chromebooks
and computers if your district isn't
doing that
i'm i'm afraid they're gonna have to
rely on mobile devices as for internet a
lot of isp providers are providing
students with months of free internet
hot spots i know here in california
xfinity is doing it it's two months free
i'm a little
lucky in that our district has already
formed some contracts so we have some
hot spots that we're able to give out to
the kids and our district is 99 one to
one
we have like i think the adult learning
and a few other ones might not be
um so we're able to check out the
chromebooks and send them home
um
oh but again they're going to have to
rely on mobile devices and get creative
uh i wish there was another way to put
it but here's the cool thing
google classroom and every most of these
apps are also compatible and i haven't
tested it with khan academy
but i do think it would work because
it's not flash enabled or anything like
that
most game systems have a built-in web
browser
you can use
90
of digital learning activities
on these game systems using their web
browser
so even if your kids just have a
playstation 4 there's a way for them to
get into distance learning they have to
figure it out and take the time to play
with it and trust me 80 of our kids are
better at technology than us
and i'm in my early 30s and some of my
kids have figured out things that i
don't know
cool and so i'm seeing a lot of
questions pouring here where folks are
saying this is amazing but can we take
one big step back and just talk about
like how do you even assign stuff in the
first place so if you wouldn't mind sort
of walking us through that i'll mimic
what you're saying on the screen here
lisa
so
i first of all sign into my teacher
account
and then there is a nice fancy little
tab that says classes students and
resources
your student ones are individual and
that just lets you monitor their
progress resources are ways you can use
this
how you can use it different things like
that it's kind of like a help button for
for the teacher
um and then under classes
you pick your class
so we have all of these neat little
classes we're just going to go with
algebra one under assignments you see a
little button it's a drop down button so
you have to
click it down if it doesn't auto drop
because it'll look like that and you go
to assign
and it allows you to pick things based
on
the topic at hand so i always pick
fourth grade
and then i pick whatever we're working
on so
early math is usually a good one to go
with if i have specific students that i
know are struggling with something i'll
click around to where they need
let's go with counting small numbers you
click the little check box
and
it will um
assign everything under that window
but in here you've only got the
worksheet now if you look at counting
the lesson it does all the videos plus
the little quizzes so i always pick the
whole lesson unless i just need a
student to review then i just pick the
video
then you hit assign
and it will show up to the students
that you choose or your entire class
and i always have the randomized option
for the questions i don't do the same
question set because then the kids can
share answers it's a way to discourage
you know fibbing
um if it's only one or two students i'll
find them in the drop down menu under
students and just click those students
if it's all of my students i do it i try
to give them a large window when i'm
doing the whole lesson
because they need that time to digest
the video and go back and review it
so i usually give them about about a
week yeah about a week and then you hit
assign
and what ends up happening with that
is it pushes it out to the students and
the students can check on it now the way
the students check on it is a little
different
so if you go to is this a student a fake
student profile
yeah and so just to be clear you can
always see what students see by going up
to your name in the upper right hand
corner and going from your teacher
dashboard to your learner home because
you also have a student view
yes and so it'll show all of their
little goodies and if you look there's
little badges and prize points and all
that mastery points
but if they go they can go and they
click assignments
and that's where all the teacher
assigned work is
so here they have everything they did it
shows what they did the videos always
show as completed the lesson overall
shows is completed but the actual work
shows the percentage they got correct or
completed
so in this case the student is scoring
hundreds i would start applying much
harder work
to find out where that student is
struggling so i know where the student
needs to focus when they are within the
classroom
very cool
hopefully that gives folks a sense of
how to get started one last question for
you before we wrap up here i know there
are some more questions coming in
if folks want to sort of get to the next
level okay i've played around with khan
academy maybe even my students have
played around with it now but i have
more questions i want to get more help
more support
any recommendations lisa based on all
the resources out there
youtube
sal has so many videos on youtube on how
to use khan academy they're actually
linked on the khan academy website again
under that my resources there are
training videos
training videos that show you how to use
it
um there's also i believe a contact us
option where if you're really really
stuck i think you can email
um
i've been lucky i've never had to use it
yeah and let me actually just pause you
for one second because this is so
important um i was actually on the phone
with comcast for about four hours this
weekend and so i know that like everyone
is struggling to provide customer
service
con county however has completely ramped
up our offerings here and so now if you
go to the help section again it's your
name and help right over here
you can come over to the section called
report a problem and it could be a
technical issue or it could just be how
do i assign assignments i forgot what
lisa told me we were happy to answer any
and all questions and here's the really
incredible part even in the midst of
this crisis even as a non-profit we
typically respond within a couple of
hours so if you have other questions
that were not answered today this is a
great place to go and get some support
yeah and i'll tell you right now we used
to use this support program in my
district and i had this student
oddly enough he was an eel but his math
skills were amazing
the scaffold program that we had built
into our curriculum he beat in four
months in the school year so less than
than a third of the way through the
school year he was done i put him on
khan academy
i still to this day give him assignments
even though he's now in sixth grade
because he is breezing through our
current curriculum
so i've reached out to his grade level
teacher and i'm like yo he's still in my
khan academy classrooms i'm still seeing
his work would you like me to assign him
other challenging things and his
teachers are like yes please oh my
goodness he's already done with our
curriculum stuff online and i'm like
okay cool no problem
so it's also a good way if you're a
parent intent you can set up a parent
account
through your teacher account
and you can actually set your kids up on
this if you want to give them extra help
too
so it isn't just as teachers
and it's amazing and
i am so grateful that sal took the time
to go from doing this just on youtube to
doing this on his own website
absolutely and you know lisa i want to
thank you for sharing so much expertise
and knowledge with us today
if you were just sort of finished up
with any words of wisdom as educators
across the country are thinking about
wow i've got a lot of my shoulders right
now
how do i move forward in this
challenging moment any last sort of
words of advice you want to share
breathe take it one day at a time
one lesson at a time
remember
the kids are just as up in the air as we
are
the districts are just up in the air as
we are the parents are just up in the
air as we are
give them work that you know they can do
give them work that will challenge them
but don't expect them to be
100
just
breathe and let them learn at their pace
because now we don't have to teach the
test standardized testing is suspended
let them
learn at their pace
they've got this we've got this we need
to be calm for them
wow i couldn't say it better myself lisa
thank you so much for leaving us with a
little inspiration on our otherwise
tough day and thank you everyone for
investing time in this session um you
will have a recording after this in your
email feel free to share with um fellow
colleagues and thank you again lisa for
making us all a little smarter
not a problem everybody good luck have
an awesome rest of the year as best we
can
cheers
bye